[Music]
when you get
desperate
afraid
or angry
the
higher thinking parts of your brain shut
down
and you don't make
good decisions so i have found in my
life once i get if i get greedy
if i get
afraid if i get desperate
right after that i get stupid
and right after i get stupid i get broke
er
and so that's what's happening in the
housing market right now
because oh god the house prices are up
and oh god the interest rates went up
and oh god i'm never gonna be able to
get a house oh god and once your brain
starts doing that you're getting ready
to do something stupid party's over
there's gonna be a lot of regret and
they call into this show and go dave i
did something stupid dave help me so
where were you three years ago when i
was doing something stupid i was sitting
right here that's where i've been for
that
move i'm still here
and i'm still telling you the same
things
about money because these principles
that we teach are timeless now we teach
people to get out of that and stay out
of that when it comes to a house it's
the only debt we don't yell at you for
and we always have told you and we still
will tell you even with the house price
is so high
to get a 15-year fixed rate
where the payment is no more than a
fourth of your take-home pay now why do
we do that just because we're killjoys
kind just because we don't want life to
be good for you
no we do that because we love you
we care about your financial future more
than that banker does more than the
mortgage companies do we're not making
money off of this off of the you getting
a mortgage or not getting a mortgage or
you getting a house or not getting a
house it's okay
we're okay
you're okay
but here's the thing
if you get in crazy mode because of
what's going on out there
you're going to buy too much house
you're going to put it on a 30-year
and you're going to be stuck in the
middle class or lower middle-class loop
all in the name of buying a house
because buying a house is financially
smart if i can't get one now i'll never
go well they're throwing money away dave
they're throwing money away
that's the argument calm down
it sounds like a weather forecaster when
there's a tornado warning that's the way
your brain sounds oh god you know that's
the super bowl that's where they get to
create all the fear oh man
so yeah that's that and when your brain
is doing that
so you know and people do it when you
know the first time i ever heard it was
like okay i live in california math
doesn't work in california well we kind
of know that but yes it does for
different reasons a lot of psychedelic
drugs involved in this but yes it does
work yeah so here's the thing
speaking of california math
cbs news is reporting one of the biggest
hurdles in buying a home is coming up
with a hefty down payment
california
has a new program to end quotes help
first time home buyers jump that hurdle
what do you think george
oh boy keep reading you got it
california's forgivable equity builder
loan allows first-time home buyers who
have enough income for a monthly
mortgage payment to borrow up to 10
percent of a home's purchase price to
buy a house outright the loan has an
interest rate of zero percent but
borrowers who don't occupy the home for
at least five years may have to repay
the loan
what a concept so you can borrow your
down payment
at zero percent from california the new
effort comes as real estate prices have
hit record highs
in california and rising interest rates
have pushed
monthly payments
up hundreds of dollars
this is the way people's brains sound
i'm telling you i know exactly how your
brain sounds
because this is how mine sounds right
before i do some stupid butt stuff
it sounds like a beagle chasing a rabbit
is that what it sounds like i don't know
something like that but i mean your
brain your brain is shutting down but a
standard down payment of 20 for a home
in california could cost upwards of a
hundred thousand dollars well no kidding
that's the thing if you get a million
dollar home and they're letting you
borrow up to ten percent at zero percent
interest so letting you borrow 100 grand
you still then have to go get a 900 000
mortgage
and that's if your income qualifies
that's assuming you qualify but here's
the problem okay
you can't look out there five years in
the future
and know what stupid butt stuff the
state of california is going to do that
makes you want to leave
and you can't leave because then you
have to repay that loan head into dan
today here is the thing
so even crazy people that believe in
debt are saying don't do it aren't they
george yeah oh yeah credit karma came
out and said this is probably a bad idea
if credit karma is saying don't borrow
the money
this tells you don't borrow the money i
mean this is like daniel's telling you
not to drink bourbon okay
i mean that's
it's some bad bourbon right it's got to
be bad oh my god and i looked into this
your income has to be less than 80
percent of the area median income
and so they're saying if you're broke
enough you can then afford all of this
and like i said with the numbers housing
in california not cheap so even with the
borrowed money they're allowing people
to borrow way more to get into homes
they can't afford okay so these are less
than 80 so you're eight eight tenths of
the median the middle income of the area
so this is um
middle income or lower middle income
people only that are going to get in
this trap
yeah which are the people that can't get
out
so god do they get asked listen i'm
making fun of you because i know how
your brain sounds i know that some of
you have a valid concern about buying a
home in this market it's scary out there
house prices have shot up like crazy
all the indications of all the data from
the industry is it's going to calm down
no it's not going to come down it's
going to calm down
and data that george and i saw in a
meeting yesterday was that uh
in 2020 house prices went up 32 percent
uh in 21 they went up what was it 18.
and i was uh 14 i think okay and they're
expecting them this year to go up seven
percent so it's slowing down so the rate
of in and the average house price year
is about four percent okay over the last
25 30 years so we've had this huge spike
post pandemic
the spike is tapering off there will
continue to be a an appreciation an
increase in value but it will be a more
reasonable and no you're not going to
get priced out of the market if you
continue to grow your career you
continue to manage money well are you
going to buy a house right now probably
not you might be too broke to buy a
house right now you might be too broke
to buy a car right now you might be too
broke to go on vacation right now so
don't do it
but dave i gotta live my life yeah yolo
baby yolo
i'm serious it all this stuff is
temporary
and so calm your butt down
don't use the emotions
of the current
inflationary cycle
to uh cause you to dive off the deep end
into a pool with no water it's just
don't do it
don't
do it calm
down
this is the ramsey show